[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Wulf schmiese guten Abend
bei uns geht es hier zur Zeit zu wie
überall ein Krankenstand auf
Rekordniveau höher als in den
corona-jahren und Grund sind vor allem
Erkältungskrankheiten die es vor Corona
auch schon gab aber ja auch dabei ist
kovid 19 das wie der Name sagt nun 3
Jahre alt ist aber es hat seinen
Schrecken offenbar verloren jetzt wird
das Ende aller staatlichen
corona-maßnahmen gefordert vorhin habe
ich Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
dazu befragt denn die Pandemie ist
vorbei das jedenfalls sagt der Professor
der vor dem Virus immer gewarnt hat
Heikes lanski berichtet
es sind schon wieder die Wissenschaftler
die der Politik den Takt vorgeben dieses
Mal ist es Christian Drosten einer der
führenden Virologen eher vorsichtig in
der corona-zeit immer nah am Minister
die Pandemie würde jetzt in eine Endemie
übergehen also in eine ziemlich
gewöhnliche Krankheit für manche kommt
das nicht überraschend ich glaube auch
dass wir davon sprechen können dass ich
jetzt die Pandemie im Zustand des
Übergangs in die Endemie befindet das
kann man daran sehen dass wir aktuell
relativ stabile stagnieren
Infektionszahlen haben mit leichten
Schwankungen und das ist wahrscheinlich
dann doch wesentlich der Tatsache
geschuldet dass wir inzwischen andere
die Breite Immunität in der Bevölkerung
vor allem durch Impfung aber auch
Genesung haben der Bundesjustizminister
fackelt nicht lange schreibt umgehen
seinem ampelkollegen dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister mit dem er
bislang mühsame Kompromisse ausgehandelt
hat lieber Karl so heißt es zurück zur
Normalität die Pandemie ist die Ausnahme
Freiheit ist die Regel wir sollten an
Gesichts der erfreulichen pandemischen
Entwicklung zum Regelfall zurückkehren
und die bundesweiten Schutzmaßnahmen
außer Kraft setzen der Minister hält
wenig davon und schickt erst einmal
seinen Parteifreund zum Gegenangriff vor
wenn Herr Buschmann jetzt appelliert zu
diesem Gesetz was er selber mit
beschlossen hat dann appelliert er an
die Länder ich würde sagen wir erleben
jetzt noch vier Monate Abschiedstournee
desinfektionsschutzgesetzes und wenn es
dann keine Mutation gibt dann wird es
auch wirklich in die Phase der
Eigenverantwortung übergehen müssen noch
gilt laut Infektionsschutzgesetz
bundesweit bis Anfang April eine
maskenpflicht im öffentlichen
Fernverkehr in Arztpraxen Krankenhäusern
und Pflegeeinrichtungen alles andere ist
Ländersache manche haben sowohl die
isolationspflicht bei einem positiven
Test abgeschafft als auch die
maskenpflicht im Nahverkehr ich halte es
für sinnvoll dass wir jetzt in dieser
Endphase der Pandemie nicht übers Knie
brechen oder ihn mit stolperschritten
wichtige und einfache Schutzmaßnahmen
aus der Hand geben die Kliniken auch im
dritten corona-winter am Limit
Personalausfälle lange Wartezeiten
notfallbetrieb allerdings wegen
Influenza und RS Viren nicht mehr wegen
Corona deshalb fordert die FDP ich bin
eindeutig dafür dass wir aus der
maskenpflicht in einer maskenempfehlung
übergehen sollten wie es bereits in
vielen Ländern der Welt auch stattfindet
Deutschland wird jetzt nicht waghalsiger
oder als erstes Land diese Maßnahmen
betreiben sondern andere Länder haben es
bereits vorgemacht Streit in der
Ampelkoalition um staatlich verordnete
Maßnahmen auf der Suche nach einer
gesichtswarenden Exit-Strategie
hier ist der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach guten Abend
guten Abend ist denn die Pandemie nun
vorbei oder nicht
es ist richtig dass wir jetzt in einen
endemischen Zustand übergehen das heißt
die Wellen die jetzt kommen die erfassen
nicht mehr die gesamte Bevölkerung
sondern nur noch die Teile der
Bevölkerung den nicht ausreichend
geimpft sind oder Menschen die vor
Schäden haben somit ist also eine große
Welle die gesamte Bevölkerung erfassen
würde im Moment nicht zu erwarten weil
die neuen Varianten die gekommen sind
die sind nicht so anstecken und auch
nicht so gefährlich wie es vor einigen
Monaten im Labor noch aussah somit die
Situation entschärft sich etwas und
deswegen hat der Kollege Marco Buschmann
Ihnen heute diesen Brief geschrieben der
Bundesjustizminister schlägt darin vor
dass die bundesweiten
corona-schutzmaßnahmen außer Kraft
gesetzt werden sollten Sie haben ihm
noch nicht schriftlich geantwortet was
antworten Sie ihm jetzt hier
die Antwort auf keinen Fall hier
öffentlich und wir werden auch keine
öffentlichen Briefe also zitieren
sondern wir werden miteinander reden
über das ja immer gemacht haben wie das
in der ampelko Koalition auch richtig
ist
wahr ist wir müssen über die Lage reden
auf der anderen Seite ist es auch
wiederum so jetzt überstürzt alle
Maßnahmen fahren zu lassen oder aus
meiner Sicht wenig Sinn machen das
verlangt ja auch Herr Drosten nicht wir
haben im Moment noch also volle
Krankenhäuser selbst die Kinder können
nicht gut versorgt werden wir haben eine
hohe Übersterblichkeit sterben noch
jeden Tag Menschen an Corona die nicht
unbedingt sterben müssen und wir haben
noch eine Bevölkerung die geschützt
werden muss insbesondere in
Krankenhäusern aber auch diejenigen die
gefährdet sind weil sie
Begleiterkrankungen haben am
Arbeitsplatz somit würden wir jetzt
alles sofort fallen lassen dann würde
natürlich die Belastung zunehmen in
einer Art und Weise wie es nicht gut
vertretbar wäre richtig ist wir können
nach dem Winter mit einer deutlich
entspannteren Situation rechnen dann hat
es gibt so viel Immunität aufgebaut und
sagt ja auch Herr Drosten dass wir im
Sommer eine ganz andere Lage haben
werden nun haben sie selber ja schon
getwittert vor einem Jahr es wäre ein
vorgezogenes Weihnachtsgeschenk wenn
Omikron leichter verliefe und im Grunde
hatten sie recht damit haben sie ja die
Endemie also eine Krankheit wie Grippe
mit der wir leben können vorausgesagt
das ist nun eingetreten und trotzdem
höre ich raus sie wollen die Maßnahmen
auf jeden Fall weiter beibehalten sie
haben das vor einem Jahr getwittert
jetzt sagt es Herr Drosten auch wir
haben eine Endemie keine Pandemie mehr
und sie wollen trotzdem bis April weiter
festhalten an den Masken
naja wir bis April dann festhalten als
wären wir sehen aber wir sind jetzt
mitten in einer also üblen Situation die
Krankenhäuser sind total voll das
Personal ist überlastet wir haben
Schwierigkeiten Personal zu finden große
Ausfälle und wir haben eine
Übersterblichkeit seit Monaten es
sterben um die 100 bis 150 Menschen mit
oder an Corona pro Tag und somit also
ist eine sehr schnelle
Öffnung hier nicht wirklich sinnvoll
klar ist die Omegon Varianten die
gekommen sind sind nicht ganz so
ansteckend wie im Labor und auch nicht
ganz so schwer verlaufen das hatte ich
auch selbst
vorhergesagt ich habe immer gesagt wenn
eine Variante kommt die auch
delta-elemente wieder hat dann würde das
hier gefährlich werden das hat sich aber
nicht ergeben somit sind wir in einer
günstigen Situation aber wir dürfen hier
nicht aus Glatteis gehen sie haben ja
gerade gesagt ob April wie es im
Infektionsschutzgesetz geschrieben ist
nun der Endpunkt sein muss oder ob viel
früher rausgehen das können wir noch
entscheiden ja wann denn wie ist denn
ihre Exit-Strategie manche haben ja den
Eindruck sie sind wie besessen und
wollen auf jeden Fall an den
Schutzmaßnahmen festhalten
nein das ist nicht der Fall also ich bin
froh dass die Lage sich so entwickelt
und stimme der wissenschaftlichen
Einschätzung von Herrn Drosten oder auch
anderen zu ich habe es ja selbst auch
ungefähr so vorhergesagt das ist somit
eine gute Entwicklung aber ich frage
mich ob es jetzt wirklich auf ein paar
Wochen ankommt wo wir jetzt in einer so
kritischen Situation sind auch wenn ich
warten wollen bis wir diese jetzt
laufende winterwelle hinter uns haben da
kommt es doch jetzt nach drei Jahren
Pandemie noch ein paar Wochen nicht an
werden wir jetzt in einer ganz
besonderen Situation sind auch was das
Personal angeht also somit also wir
werden uns da bewegen ganz klar aber der
rechtliche Rahmen ist ja derzeit noch
komplett abgedeckt also wir haben ein
geltendes Infektionsschutzgesetz das
haben wir entwickelt als die Zahlen
schlechter waren als sie jetzt sind aber
in der gleichen Größenordnung Herr
Minister ich habe eine frage noch zu
China da fallen ja nun fast alle
Maßnahmen zum Schutz vor Corona sogar
die Quarantäne Pflicht für
Geschäftsleute nach Einreise könnte denn
nun dort eine gefährliche Variante
entstehen die dann zu uns zurückkommt
das wäre im Prinzip möglich dass es
etwas wovor viele Wissenschaftler Angst
haben auch in den Vereinigten Staaten
das wird intensiv untersucht wir können
nur hoffen dass es nicht so ist also
Corona wird gefährlich bleiben man kann
auch nicht das mit der Grippe
vergleichen die Grippe also ist eine
Atemwegserkrankung die
corona-erkrankungen befähigt die Gefäße
die werden also nach mehrfachen
corona-befall auch schlechter die
Immunität ganz schlechter werden
zumindest gibt ganz kategorische
Unterschiede zwischen corona-infektionen
und Gefäß Beteiligung auf der einen
Seite und der Grippe auf der anderen
Seite wir müssen hier auch darauf achten
dass auch dauerhaft unnötige Infektionen
vermieden werden dafür brauchen wir aber
nicht mehr die Einschränkungen die wir
immer gehabt haben Minister Lauterbach
vielen Dank für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
und ausführlich zur Lage in China
berichten wir nachher im heute schon mal
Update und darin befragt Nazan gökt die
mir auch ein Intensivmediziner zur
corona-lage
der FDP-Politiker Alexander Graf
Lamsdorf der hier neben Vladimir
Klitschko steht der soll nächstes Jahr
einen der heikelsten Jobs Deutschlands
übernehmen nämlich Botschafter in
Russland das berichten mehrere Medien
Lamsdorf ist ausgebildeter Diplomat aber
und deshalb ist seine Personalie
interessant er sieht keine rein
diplomatische Lösung die Russlands
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine beenden
könnte
doch in letzter Zeit versprechen beide
Seiten von Verhandlungslösungen Russland
wie die Ukraine was ist konkret dran
dominik leßmeister hat sich damit
befasst
seit sechs Monaten versucht Russland die
ostukrainische Stadt bachmut einzunehmen
immer wieder steht die Stadt unter
Beschuss sie liegt direkt an der
Frontlinie die Kämpfe im Osten der
Ukraine sind besonders hart die Verluste
hoch für beide Seiten ein
abnutzungskrieg
bisher war die Ukraine zurückhaltend was
Verhandlungen angeht nun schlägt der
ukrainische Außenminister in einem
Interview mit der Nachrichtenagentur API
einen internationalen Friedensgipfel vor
einerseits geht es darum nicht
zuzulassen das Russland die
Friedensfrage manipuliert weil es
regelmäßig sagt dass es zu Verhandlungen
bereit sei was nicht stimmt weil sie
alles was sie auf dem Schlachtfeld tun
das Gegenteil beweist sie suchen keinen
Frieden
andererseits sieht cool lieber die
Vereinten Nationen als Vermittler Moskau
müsse sich allerdings zuerst für
Kriegsverbrechen verantworten ehe sein
Land direkt verhandelt
von russlands Präsident Putin heute bei
einem Treffen früherer so wird
Republiken in St Petersburg keine
Reaktion die Ukraine müsste sämtliche
Forderungen Russlands erfüllen sagte
Außenminister
was die Dauer des Konflikts angeht so
liegt der Ball auf der Seite des Kiefer
Regimes und Washingtons das ihm den
Rücken stärkt Moskau hat immer wieder
wiederholt dass es von den Kriegszielen
die es am ersten Tag des Krieges gehabt
hat nicht abrückt und von daher ist da
wirklich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
zumindest kein Signal aus Moskau das ist
irgendwelchen Spielraum wirklich für
Verhandlungen gibt im Gegenteil moskau
will Gebiete haben die es zur Zeit nicht
kontrolliert so wie in bachmut wo die
Menschen unter russischem Dauerbeschuss
gerade wenig Hoffnung auf Frieden haben
in Kiew ist unsere reporterin Anne Brühl
guten Abend Anne was ist denn von dem
ukrainischen Vorschlag eines
friedensgipfels zu halten also was was
steckt dahinter
na das kann man schon so als eine Art
Testballon sehen da spricht jetzt der
ukrainische Außenminister deutlicher als
viele vor ihm von Friedensgesprächen bei
Präsident selensky kann das immer ein
bisschen kryptischer er hat von
Anstrengungen zum Frieden gesprochen
beim G20-Gipfel auch in seiner Rede zur
Fußball-WM und er hat immer die
ukrainische Bereitschaft dazu
signalisiert und von Russland Taten
gefordert und da liegt natürlich genau
die Crocs denn diese Taten gibt es ja
nicht im Gegenteil die Angriffe hier auf
die Infrastruktur im Land die gehen
weiter heute Abend sind 9 Millionen
Ukraine von der Stromversorgung
abgeschnitten das ist fast ein Viertel
der Gesamtbevölkerung und warum kommt
der Vorschlag gerade jetzt
da lässt vor allen Dingen Einsatz aus
diesem Interview des Außenministers
aufhorchen nämlich dieser die Ukraine
Unternehmer alles um den Krieg 2023 zu
gewinnen da spielt sicherlich ein
bisschen Wunschdenken mit andererseits
muss man ja schon sagen dass die
militärischen Erfolge der Ukraine in den
vergangenen sechs Monaten durchaus
bemerkenswert sind sie sind natürlich
auch zustande gekommen durch die
westlichen Waffen die hierher geliefert
wurden und man muss sich natürlich auch
fragen was hat die Ukraine militärisch
noch in der Hinterhand es gibt Geraune
auch über eine neue Offensive
möglicherweise im Süden möglicherweise
Richtung melittopoll Richtung Krim und
so wirkt dieser Vorstoß des
Außenministers heute in zwei Richtungen
Friedensinitiative zum einen zum anderen
aber auch Demonstration der eigenen
Stärke
danke Anne Brühl nach Kiew
und es gibt Sorge um einen möglichen
weiteren Krieg in Europa und damit
beginnen die Nachrichten mit Hanna
Zimmermann die Spannungen zwischen
Serbien und dem Kosovo nehmen weiter zu
in der Stadt Mitrovica im Norden des
Kosovos haben Serben weitere
Straßensperren errichtet beladene
Lastwagen blockieren dort die Durchfahrt
am Montagabend hatte die Regierung in
Belgrad zudem ihre Armee in höchste
Kampfbereitschaft versetzt zur
Begründung hieß es Präsident wucic sei
überzeugt dass die kosovarische
Regierung einen Angriff auf die im
Kosovo lebenden Serben vorbereite das
Kosovo hat früher zu Serbien gehört und
ist seit 2008 unabhängig Serbien erkennt
dies allerdings nicht an
angesichts des von den Taliban
verhängten arbeitsverbots für Frauen in
Hilfsorganisationen hat der
un-hochkommissar für Menschenrechte Türk
vor einer Destabilisierung Afghanistans
gewarnt und ein Ende der Einschränkungen
gefordert mehrere Medien berichteten
zugleich über ein vertrauliches
Gesprächsprotokoll zwischen Vertretern
der UN und der islamistischen Führung
laut dem es offenbar Ausnahmen geben
soll so gelte das verboten nicht für die
Vereinten Nationen und für Frauen die in
Gesundheitsbereich Arbeiten
vor dem Hintergrund der zunehmenden
Bedrohung durch China hat Taiwan
beschlossen den Wehrdienst von vier auf
zwölf Monate zu verlängern Präsidentin
sei erklärte Taiwan wolle keinen Krieg
aber das Land habe den Mut und die
Entschlossenheit die Demokratie zu
verteidigen china hatte in den
vergangenen Tagen erneut eine umfassende
Militärübung abgehalten und dabei 71
Kampfjets so wie sieben Schiffe über die
in spezielle Grenze in die Straße von
Taiwan geschickt
die Bundesregierung hatten diesem Jahr
wieder Rüstungsexporte in großem Umfang
genehmigt obwohl sich die Ampelkoalition
eigentlich vorgenommen hatte die
Ausfuhren zurückzufahren bislang
belaufen sich die Exporte auf mindestens
8,35 Milliarden Euro das ist der
zweithöchste Wert in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik davon entfallen
allerdings
2,24 Milliarden auf Lieferungen an die
Ukraine darunter auch viele schwere
Waffen
das hier das ist eine Stadt in der Stadt
die Hafencity in Hamburg und die Idee
dazu die wurde vor 25 Jahren präsentiert
um Wohnraum zu schaffen für 15.000
Menschen und Büroraum für 45.000 es ist
das größte innerstädtische
Stadtentwicklungsprojekt Europas Martin
Niesen hat geschaut was daraus geworden
ist und wie alles begann
wie ein Leuchtturm die Hafen Einfahrt
markiert die Elbphilharmonie den Beginn
der HafenCity Europas größtes
Städtebauprojekt auf über 150 Hektar
ehemaligen Hafen und Industrieareal mit
Architektur die polarisiert zwischen
begeisternd und beliebig und mit
Wohnraum für 15000 Menschen
ich glaube man kann schon sehr zufrieden
sein mit dem das Hamburg hier geschaffen
hat
eine Metropole die die einen
strukturellen Wandel genutzt hat und
brachliegende Potenziale für sich
gewonnen hat und damit eigentlich auch
eine neue Interpretation der Inneren
Stadt geboren hat
1997 hatte der damalige erste
Bürgermeister Henning Forscher rau die
Vision HafenCity vorgestellt der
verkauft städtischer Grundstücke sollte
den Ausbau der Container Terminals im
Hafen finanzieren ein Geburtsfehler der
HafenCity monieren Kritiker der Schulhof
aus Platzmangel hinter Fangzäune aufs
Dach verlegt Häuser Schluchten in denen
es kaum Grünflächen gibt und keine
Radwege manches würde er heute anders
machen gibt der langjährige
Oberbaudirektor zu vieles aber auch
nicht wenn wir solche zentrale lagen
haben geht es auch darum dass wir das
Bauen etwas konzentrieren eine gewisse
dichte schaffen und das ist deshalb
notwendig weil wir damit allein die
Chance haben eine voranzubringen und
wertvolle Grünflächen die wir noch
besitzen am Rande der Stadt aber auch in
der Stadt tatsächlich zu schützen vor
weiterer Bebauung Iris neidmann hält
wenig von dieser Argumentation sie
betreibt eine Galerie ist Mitbegründerin
der Initiative lebenswerter HafenCity
und selbst Architektin das widerspricht
dem Aspekt der klimaresilienz der
Klimaanpassung wir brauchen unbedingt
mehr Grün hier um für die hitzevorsorge
und weniger Wind zu sorgen auch um die
Luft zu verbessern durch den Kreuzfahrt
Terminal und die Nähe zum Hafen werden
Grenzwerte für Feinstaub und Stickoxide
gerissen ein riesiger Shopping komplex
und zunehmender Verkehr dürften das
Problem noch verschärfen
wenn wir hier als Anwohner und viele
Architekten aus der Stadt die sich auch
engagiert haben Kritik vorgetragen haben
wurde die einfach überhaupt nicht
beachtet immerhin galt die HafenCity
zunächst als Spielwiese für Immobilien
Spekulanten und Superreiche sind
mittlerweile viele Familien mit Kindern
hergezogen ein knappes Drittel der
Wohnungen ist gefördert weitere Schulen
geplant Städtebau als Lernprozess es
wäre ja schön wenn wir nur am Anfänger
und Fehler gemacht hätten ich hoffe dass
wir nicht allzu viele Fehler jetzt noch
machen aber ich glaube eine gute Stadt
entwickelt auch nur wenn Sie zu den
viele Entwicklungen steht und darauf
reagiert schon jetzt ist die HafenCity
ein Touristenmagnet nicht nur wegen der
Elbphilharmonie ab 2025 soll ein
Leuchtturm auch hier anderes Ende
markieren das mit Abstand höchste
Gebäude der Hansestadt der elbauer
[Musik]
wohnen braucht Wärme doch nun könnte es
mit der Energie noch knapper werden
hannah hat dazu weitere Nachrichten die
heute als Eilmeldung kam ja Russland
verbietet ab Februar Ölexporte in alle
Länder die den Ölpreis Deckel
beschlossen haben das geht aus einem
Dekret hervor dass der russische
Präsident Putin heute unterzeichnet hat
und da wollen wir Nachfragen bei Valerie
Halle an der Frankfurter Börse was für
Auswirkungen könnte dieses Verbot denn
jetzt haben kurzfristig vermutlich keine
die EU will ja ohnehin größten Teils auf
russisches Öl verzichten Putin hat auch
von Anfang an erklärt dass er diesen
preisdeckel ablehnt dass Dekret war
daher keine Überraschung vor ein paar
Tagen hat Russland zudem angekündigt im
kommenden Jahr weniger ölfördern zu
wollen beides zielt darauf ab Druck auf
die Ölmärkte auszuüben genau da setzt
Putin an Russland verkauft durch die
Sanktionen wahrscheinlich weniger Öl
höhere Preise aber könnten diesen
Verlust eventuell ausgleichen seit
Anfang Dezember gilt der preisdeckel für
Öltransporte mit dem Tanker europäische
Schiffe dürfen nun kein russisches Öl
mehr befördern das mehr als 60 Dollar
pro Barrel kostet das Kalkül dahinter
die üppigen Öleinnahmen zu schmälern und
damit Russlands Kriegsfinanzierung zu
erschweren und tatsächlich ist Öl für
Russland wichtigstes Export gut Moskau
kann zwar teilweise auf Märkte wie
Indien und China ausweichen aber die
allermeisten ökonomen erwarten dass
diese Länder weniger abnehmen als die EU
das getan hat kann man denn schon
absehen ob der preisdeckel überhaupt
funktioniert das ist noch völlig unklar
Russland wird natürlich versuchen den
preisdeckel zu umgehen laut Medien
berichten kaufte Kreml massiv alte Tanke
auf um nicht länger auf westliche Rede
rein angewiesen zu sein die er den
preisdeckel einhalten müssen ob die
Rechnung aufgeht das können wir jetzt
noch nicht sagen vielen Dank Valerie
nach Frankfurt
die deutschen Wirtschaftsverbände
blicken deutlich pessimistischer in die
Zukunft als im vergangenen Jahr das
zeigt eine Umfrage des Instituts der
deutschen Wirtschaft aktuell erwarten 30
von 49 Verbänden einen
Produktionsrückgang im Jahr 2023 noch
vor einem Jahr war es kein einziger
gewesen Grund sein laut IW unter anderem
die Energiekrise und die geopolitische
Lage allerdings laut der Umfrage rechnen
die Verbände nicht mit einem Einbruch
der Investitionen und auch die
Beschäftigungslage dürfte relativ stabil
bleiben
die Speicherstände der deutschen
Gasspeicher sind in den vergangenen
Tagen wieder gestiegen und liegen
aktuell bei rund 88 Prozent Grund dafür
sein unter anderem die milden
Temperaturen und das windige Wetter
erklärte der Chef der Bundesnetzagentur
Müller dadurch sei weniger geheizt und
mehr Windenergie erzeugt worden zudem
wurde weniger Gas nach Frankreich
exportiert
nach dem verheerenden Wintersturm in den
USA ist die vorläufige Bilanz
erschütternd etwa 60 Menschen kamen ums
Leben die meisten von ihnen im Westen
des Bundesstaats New York dort hatten
die Bewohner mit arktischen Temperaturen
zu kämpfen Schneeverwehungen türkten
sich bis zu drei Meter auf zusätzlich
macht einen Stromausfälle dort wie auch
in anderen Teilen des Landes die Lage
lebensbedrohlich betroffen waren fast
zwei Millionen Haushalte
und auch in New York City der herrschte
über Weihnachten Eiseskälte wie schon in
vielen Wintern zuvor doch diese Ikone
aller citys weltweit die kann nichts
wirklich niederstrecken so scheint es
weder der elfte September noch die
corona-krise vor zwei Jahren sie
erinnern sich als dort die Gräber knapp
worden immer wieder hat sich New York
neu erfunden und tut es derzeit wieder
wie Johannes Hanau erzählt unser New
York Korrespondent
jeder glaubt diese Stadt zu kennen aber
niemand kennt sie wirklich es ist ein
Streifzug durch eine Stadt die sich
nicht unterkriegen lässt Begegnungen mit
Menschen nicht aufgeben und nach
Lösungen suche auch wenn man wieder
nichts vorangeht oft nicht zu schwache
spritzt nur mit iGo der anonym bleiben
will weil seine Auslegung der New Yorker
Straßenverkehrsordnung nicht unbedingt
von allen geteilt wird Angstschweiß auf
der Stirn
du musst selbstbewusst sein und die
Sache ernst nehmen denn wenn du
unschlüssig bist oder zu lange brauchst
du meine Entscheidung zu treffen kann
sich die Lücke schließen
musst schnelle Entscheidungen treffen ob
du willst oder nicht
nach vorne schauen nicht lang fackeln
das sein Charakterzüge der New Yorker
die die Stadt am Leben halten würden
wir haben uns mit Corin Mountain
verabredet sie weiß worum es geht in
dieser Stadt sie selbst arbeitet mit
amythos der unverwüstlichen
Weltmetropole Corinne ist influencerin
sucht und teilt die neuesten Trends fomo
heißt die erfolgreicher instagram-kanal
vier auf missing out Angst etwas zu
verpassen
seines früher Filme und Fernsehserien
gewesen die den Mythos der Stadt am
Laufen gehalten hätten so sein es heute
die influence of Instagram und tiktok
durch die die Stadt Lehne
jedes Foto ist kostenlose Werbung auf
Instagram oder tiktok du möchtest also
so viele Leute wie möglich anziehen mit
so vielen Followern wie möglich um
kostenlose Werbung zu bekommen alles ist
Werbung
überall in der Stadt entstehen wieder
wundersame faszinierende coole Orte
Bohnen sie im Aufmerksamkeit jagen sie
ihren Träumen nach
ashen das ist ihr Künstlername ist 23
Jahre alt Kim jamaikanische Einwanderer
12 Stunden am Tag schlägt sie sich als
Kellnerin in einem Hotel-Restaurant
durch seit sie 14 ist schreibt sie
Gedichte Songtexte komponiert
beschäftigt sich mit der Stadt in der
sie aufgewachsen ist
[Musik]
ihren Songs geht es um den mentalen und
finanziellen Druck in die Stadt aufbaut
die gesellschaftlichen Erwartungen und
wie sich alles gegenseitig verstärkt New
York seine harte forderte Stadt für Dido
gewappnet sein musst
du kommst hierher um deinen Träumen
nachzujagen und wenn du darauf nicht
vorbereitet bist dann komm besser nicht
du weißt dass du bereit bist wenn du
nicht aufgeben willst wenn du immer
weitermachen willst New York ist der Ort
dafür denn wir schlafen nicht
nicht aufgeben und immer nur nach vorne
schauen er sind die Menschen und die
Charakter die diese Stadt immer wieder
aufstehen lassen
und die ganze Doku unseres
Korrespondenten Johannes Hano die können
Sie ab sofort in der ZDF Mediathek sehen
unter dem naheliegenden Titel New York
New York den könnten wir jetzt auch
singen aber das war es schon mit unserem
heute-journal wir beide sind morgen
wieder für Sie da und unser heute schon
mal Update gibt es dann später gegen
0:30 Uhr und wir wünschen Ihnen jetzt
noch einen angenehmen Abend und sagen
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend schnell ziehen die Tiefs
über uns hinweg Isabel Janina und
Kerstin die Janina bringt uns morgen
Regen und tief Kerstin danach Sturm es
bleibt mild bei uns und das hängt auch
zusammen mit den Hochs über Südosteuropa
und dem Mittelmeer heute Nacht also
fällt Regen zwischen dem Niederrhein und
der Ostsee sonst ist es häufig nur
locker bewölkt zum Teil bildet sich
Nebel in Südosten sinken die
Temperaturen auf -3 Grad kälter wird
zwischen der Ostsee und dem Oberrhein
bei 3 bis 1 Grad da kann es am Boden für
Frost reichen im Nordwesten das ist
milder bei sechs bis vier Grad die
Temperaturen morgen liegen zwischen vier
Grad in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen und
12 Grad am Oberrhein der Regen der Nacht
sieht morgen weiter nach Osten und am
Nachmittag kann sich ja der Nordseeküste
schon wieder mal kurz die Sonne zeigen
in der Mitte und im Süden da ist morgen
trocken und freundlich sehr sonnig
vielleicht sogar wird es im alten
Vorland am Donnerstag und am Freitag Tag
ist es im Osten meist freundlich im
Westen gibt es mehr Regenschauer und der
Silvestertag wird ungewöhnlich mit dazu
allerdings in Norddeutschland auch sehr
stürmisch das könnte ein
rekords-silvester werden vielleicht geht
es am Oberrhein bis zu 19 Grad zum
Beispiel in Freiburg im Breisgau wäre
das dann so warm wie es noch nie an
einem Silvestertag war und der letzte
Rekord übrigens der stand genau von vor
einem Jahr wir behalten das für sie im
Auge bis bald